when you do films there so you know
sandcastles you know what's a good thing
you do and that goes away and then the
next time you kind of get reacquainted
with it as when you're looping a year
later or eight months later so it's not
like the theatre where you see the same
lines and everything gets into your
blood movies are something where I'm
more likely to remember what car I was
driving to the studio then than I am the
details of shooting the film it's such a
like a mist it comes and goes so quickly
as over beetles the thing I remember
most is Michael I mean Michael came and
Keaton knew the secret because I would
act and then I'd have some doubts and I
said well maybe I this maybe I that I
was much more neurotic about what I
would do when I was very young starting
off in the films and Keane just came out
he was like the comedy Annie Oakley he
was a the mirror babe he just was so
self-assured he was so just tore it up
and we were doing a scene that's in the
movie where he spits the loogie into his
jacket which he completely improvised
he's like hey hey save that one for
later and he said the line saved that
one for later and I thought I was gonna
choke I was laughing so hard off-camera
I'm really gonna have to get to know you
guys you know we gotta get closer move
in with you for a while get to be real
what are your qualifications
well I attended truly are Keaton amazed
me and we did the movie with Tim who
would sit at a desk when we were the old
Culver studios and Tim would draw the
characters he would draw things I mean
he's an illustrator he's an artist
and he would draw and he would never
look up at me and I would say you know
10 everybody else that there's got a
thing they're doing I know you want the
dead people to be the most colorless
people than the really frightening
people are the living people you want
the ghosts to be the most
but now or whatever his language was and
I said I think I need to come up with
something where I'm like Robert Cummings
I want to I want to if you know Robert
Cummings the old actor I mean he's a
very posh kind of elegantly spoken man I
just had a hook in do you know my wife
and I are we don't have any children and
I collect antiques so I wanted to be
sort of a guy who talked like this and I
was gonna do this whole kind of campy
thing and Tim is looking down at a piece
of paper and maybe this is the only
direction Tim gave me the entire movie
he would look up and go no don't do that
go back to the paper and draw you know
you know when you do those movies with
people who are those visual assim you
just trust them you know you're doing
the movie and they said we're gonna give
you the old-age makeup and Gina and I
had the very you know kind of skull like
construct they put on us yeah they put
the straws up your nose you can breathe
they put the casts on you and they do
all the life casts and everything I'd
say it was the first time I think I'd
experience that you know you never mind
that when you're in the hands of
somebody who's as gifted as Tim I've
done not a lot but I've done a couple of
films where we did that and I was like
why don't we just cut the scene like we
just don't need this and when we did
Beetlejuice I had no idea what it was
about
I thought maybe all of our careers are
gonna end with the release of this and
we're all gonna be dead but when you're
around Tim he was just such a kind of
crazy professor you know his when we did
that scene in the HR boy was there and
he offers me a cigarette cigarette I
forget the lines that cigarette you want
a cigarette
trying to cut down myself
and we were like we couldn't handle it
yeah we just was like cracking up all
the time that's one of the earliest
movies I made and and you you see
everything that's involved in making
movies brought to bear on a movie like
that I was in a recording studio I was
in a building that was very important I
was directed a movie the only time I
directed a movie that I took my name off
of because the investors in the film
committed bank fraud and one maybe two
of them went to prison for bank fraud we
wound up calling the FBI it was in the
summer time of 2001 and I will come
outside and I would smoke a cigarette
I'd like to get some air we were in the
dark room editing and we were next door
to this fire station and that would
kibbutz with these guys and talked to
the very nice guys all of them were
killed in 9/11 not fall and Anderson
comes to this building where I'm editing
and he says he says I'm probably not
going to use this but they're kind of
insisting that I have a narration track
and I'm not going to use it I mean it's
really just it just isn't really
important and if you don't mind I'm just
asking as a favor would you record this
track and we were doing he goes just
don't put anything on - just to say it
just don't do it I'm like okay so we
just flatten it out and flatten it out
and made it more kind of basic Royal had
lived in the Lindbergh Palace Hotel for
22 years
[Music]
can you pay her in cash he was a
prominent litigator until the mid 80s
when he was disbarred and briefly
imprisoned and he was like thanks and
really very kind of you and you know
we're probably not gonna use it and then
they used it and you know it's my
favorite Wes Anderson movie because of
Hackman because of all people Wes
Anderson who I don't you know I don't
compare Wes Anderson to like John
Frankenheimer or John Ford or Coppola
you know some commanding kind of almost
swashbuckling director Anderson is a
very kind of quiet humble shy guy when I
met him and he's the one that got
happened to sit on these bad impulses he
had in the latter part of his career
where he immunized himself against all
of the events and all of the kind of
conditions of the county was playing by
playing amusment Hackman got to the
point where was almost laughing right
before he delivered every lime you see
the missiles are coming captain he'd be
like okay the missiles are coming but he
really didn't play the stakes and
Anderson got him to play the stakes in
Royalton enough to really care and
invest and flatten out that and comb out
that kind of silliness wait a second now
okay listen I'm not dying but I need
some time a month or so okay I want to I
want us to do too maybe I am dying Wes
got him to do that and I thought my god
this is the greatest performance that
hackman's given and had we made a lot of
movies is this is the greatest
performance he's given in like 10 or 15
years
I had no interest early on doing a TV
series cuz I thought I'm gonna be parked
here I was divorce from my ex-wife my
daughter was very young was about 2006 I
said to Lauren I can't do it because I
need to be able to commute back and
forth to LA every other weekend I mean I
would never compare myself to this great
actor but it's like they talk about
Brando and on the waterfront that he
said I got to go to my therapist in
Queens every Thursday whatever in or two
days a week I was kind of like I said
I'll do the pilot then they said do 12
episodes I said I'll do 6 and I was very
intimidated because they were all funny
and I'm not and even throughout the
first season I was terrified of them I
was terrified of Tina and Robert and VG
and because because the the smartest
thing I would ever say was no not
funnier than the dumbest thing they ever
said that my best idea was weaker than
their worst idea and we did the show I
remember sitting there with a cup of
coffee in my hand that was are they
going it's kind of interesting in this
if God knows it's funny they're very
funny writers years and years of market
research which led to my greatest
triumph the tribe action of GE traction
oven cooks perfect food five times
faster than a conventional oven because
it uses three kinds of heat thermal
technology for consistent temperature GE
precise air convection technology for
optimal air circulation and microwave
technology for incredible speed
with three kinds of heat you can cook a
turkey in 22 minutes and we worked out
some things the first season about the
character of the character should be he
should be good and bad at what it had
his job he should be great at his job
and they miss applied him in the
entertainment world he's widget eyes
entertainment which was always a
catastrophe of my mind and so we
wouldn't did it and after the first
season we all started to get our footing
like many shows if you watched the first
season of Will & Grace
none of them sound the way they sound
after season three and four brother tell
me that the season two it was really
just a toboggan ride it was really the
writing was so funny we won this award
in that way
season three or four it was bombs away
we won every award
when the show ended I had to do the
scene in the boat harbor town by Battery
Park and say goodbye to Tina and say
they tell her in my in my god awful way
that I loved her it's a word that comes
to us by way of the old high german luba
from the latin luebero meaning to be
pleasing so i'm going to use this word
to describe how I feel about you in the
way that our anglo-saxon forefathers
would have used it in reference to say a
hot bowl of bear meat here enemies skull
split I love you too jack
I cried you know it was really very hard
because in season 5 we all realize that
season 5 was the weakest writing wise
and the follow me season 6 was the end
so in season 5 I was saying I'm gonna do
six and I'm a deer I'm done like we've
hit the wall we're done we come back and
sees that six is as good as anything
else we've done it's it's it's a dip and
we come back and when we come back for
season 6 I say I'll do 9 or 10 let's
sign for three or four more years
because I really love the people I love
the job I thought it was kind of getting
to know what I was doing comedy wise I
was always having my doubts about that
and then Tina had her second child her
daughter Penelope and I was convinced it
was gonna end like you know just Tina
just couldn't do that kind of work
anymore Christian Karluk were there
morning noon and night
writing and like I got a sense that no
Tina must be exhausted she's a mom and
everything so she decided to do a
shorter season seven and it was over and
you know Tina's smart about probably
everything I was gonna say nearly
everything but probably everything and
it was probably a good time to go we all
run into each other and we're all like
and there's other shows like this where
they all look at each other and saying
we're never gonna have it this good
again I'll never have it that good again
[Music]
that watch cost more than your car
I made nine hundred seventy thousand
dollars last year how much you make you
see pal that's who I am
and you're nothing nice guy I don't give
a [ __ ] good father [ __ ] you go home and
play with your kids my ancient at the
time michael bloom who since passed away
he was my dear friend he was my agent
for 11 years he was very smart and he
said the Pacino had been in and out of
the role of Ricky Roma a few times but
Sheena was always got kind of a buyer's
remorse sometimes in terms of film I
don't know how true that is but he went
to the producers of the film and said if
al balks again and doesn't do the film
would you let Alec play Ricky Roma and
their what yeah and what we were led to
believe was he did walk away again and
they did offer me the part of Ricky Roma
and then you know all hell broke loose
then all of a sudden everybody gets you
know realigned and we're back in place
and Al's gonna play Ricky home and I
said to me would you play Blake and I
can I get madman on the phone and I said
to Mamet you know what I find
interesting is that you won the Pulitzer
Prize for the play why did you feel the
need to rewrite the poets of a surprise
wedding play and who should you know
talks like this he said these men are
gonna commit a crime and they're not
criminals they don't have a criminal
nature and I need to put the Vice on
them and really kind of squeeze him a
little hard to become criminals because
you are the diaz deus ex machina to come
in and put that pressure on them to do
something he said I always thought that
was a flaw in the story but when you
fooled the poetry people but he he said
I wasn't that was a flaw in the story
that we needed so he writes this
monologue and I come in and I rehearse
that's summer I believe and it was hard
to lay into those guys Here I am with
all these
I mean Eid Kevin Pacino wasn't in the
scene Jonathan what price wasn't in the
same but lemon who I had worshipped I
worshipped him in there he is
I'm being presumption was here but lemon
did a thing with me where he like kind
of encouraged me to stay where I was
with him don't warm me up don't talk to
me don't let's all stay in this ugly
place
ai da get out there you got the
prospects coming in you think they came
in to get out of the rain a guy don't
walk on the lot lest he wants to by
sitting out there waiting to give you
their money are you wouldn't take it
and we were done he was very kind to me
and said you know he paid me a really
nice compliment when we left and it was
tough you know was the rehearsal I
didn't know the line so I improvised I
think I said things in the rehearsal
there were 10 times worse then boy I was
like you know you know I said think I
said to blender one day I go you know
bah bah bah bah bah your balls remember
when you had a pair of balls old men and
what's it like this really reductive
things and they knew them it was like
you [ __ ] just stared at me you know and
I just marvel at what a great job Foley
did Jamie Foley and and one rubies and
chia was the DP what are those great
monastic DPS who hardly spoke to you
they did a great job Hunt for Red
October when I got on the plane that was
back when you're in a first-class cab in
a business class cabin in the coach
cabin and if there were 12 seats in
first class and 12 seats in business
class up the 24 people in that plane
half of them had a Tom Clancy novel in
their hands are beating it on the plane
Cardinal of the Kremlin and Red Storm
rising on from Red October whatever
hardcover paperback and I remember
getting on the plane as I came into the
front of the cabinet looked down and I
went all of them are reading a book
about a character that I'm going to play
in the first movie about that and I just
became so intimidating to me and then of
course though I get there and number one
shows up and he goes and has his his
hairpiece fit on and his wardrobe but he
comes in one day into the set and I
thought I'm so [ __ ]
I said no one's ever gonna even see me
or look at me in this movie he comes in
he said John do you go to the rushes boy
what do you attend the rushes of the
film and I said what's that is it the
dailies the projection what are we to
explain so I go and I knew what it was
but I was like I was so much stricken by
him and I said I know he was well how
would you ever expect to learn
he was so in the frequency you know he
knew where the camera was
he knew the pace he wanted to speak I
mean I wonder sometimes it being a
British act for you just keep you this
born with that gift of the pace of the
language like our fathers and our
grandfathers before us you say we play
odd deadly game once more we play our
dangerous game a game of chess against
our old adversaries the American Navy it
giving that lecture to them and as the
cameras moving around and yarn is moving
around him and he's just turning this
way here turning that way it's like he's
skiing down a hill you know he was so
talented you know he looked the way he
looked his so unspeakably handsome it
was so powerful and then he talks and
you forget within 5 seconds and he
supposed to be Russian and he said oh
they're saying our old advanced race the
American Navy and you go
doesn't sound like Russian to me at all
but you know cuz it's the sky's this God
and of course everything when you're a
movie star you have an eye on and he was
wearing this beautiful leather jacket
I've never seen anything so beautiful at
that point in my life I was quite young
then
or quite really in my career and I said
where's that jacket from you said the
wardrobe department made it for me this
blue saw leather jacket I said that's
stunning and he goes I'll have them make
one for you that's movie started to get
the boy a jacket a blue sole leather
jacket I've had a thousand memories of
him but my greatest memory was went to a
party that the producer had at his home
a lot of people involved with the film
were there and he was there with his
wife Micheline who was a little tiny
little Fox of a woman just a wonderful
woman and the tray would come by with
the champagne and he would go to reach
for glass of champagne and his wife ergo
no no no no Sean not the transition
Tanya and him go oh and then fighters
save the Traber combined with the
canapes
go to reach for a little mushroom quiche
did you go talk to him this person or
that person I sure look amigos stop
going to be very much of a party Jasmine
you know I'd worked with woody I did the
movie Alice which was his take on Juliet
of the spirits and I worked with him and
with Mia years ago then he contacted me
to do this small part the the husband of
Cate Blanchet and we did the movie and
woody I'm in my opinion what he has very
church and state between drama and
comedy and although this is a funny
moment I think it's indicative of how
would he likes to work what he's very
hermetic he's very quiet he doesn't talk
to you he came up to her in a scene we
were doing and it's a scene that was cut
from the film in which I'm kind of gas
lighting her and I'm saying well you
know you need to go see your doctor
again um get back on that medication
because she's suspicious of my behavior
which she has every right to be and
we're doing the scene and he says why
don't you will you know Edie that
Adeline will you say you know baps
should go back to you know that doctor
that you've seen and get your
prescription doctor you know come up
with some name of the doctor and he's
there with his head like looking down
like this the doctor and I go a doctor
Federman and he went nothing funny
nothing funny I was like you know I was
like in comedy would go for the funny in
here they saw you having lunch with her
taking her hand what crap who told you
that I know who was that vacuous
troublemaker Lydia am i right well you
had to be Lydia cuz I was having a
business lunch with Amy at the four
seasons hey are you nuts
you think I was having an affair I'd be
crazy enough to have it in public at the
four seasons
I don't know sometimes you drink at
lunch no maybe you're high I mean it's
obvious she's got a crush on you
Cate Blanchett is one of the most gifted
actresses alive today so she knew full
well what should we get herself into in
a dramatic role regardless of the script
of the director he really wrung her out
he'd say to have I need you to really be
coming apart you wretch you wits
and here and she'd go do it again she'd
down an espresso she'd smoke a cigarette
action she'd come in and she'd try to
beat the living daylights out of me of
this physical altercation and it got in
more and more intense and after like
nine or ten I remember like eleven takes
or twelve takes he was like okay but you
know the first five or six takes the
poor woman he was like you're not there
you you're at the end of your rope and
she got boom and she go in there and you
know show you what great actress male or
female do which they just dig down so
she was great
Mission Impossible this sir this is a
trap we're being directed hunt sir
you're still to plutonium cores in the
wind and you watch them so you get a
phone call from somebody calls your
agent they said they wanted to come to
mission impossible and for some reason
McQuarrie crews mission that whole gang
you said there go yes sir you know your
honor what time is my plane whatever is
my flight sir you go there and it's just
you're in the zone with them and because
there's nobody who's more you know and
in a warm way not in any menacing or
kind of unattractive way cruise every
day is like hi yeah you know he's like
ready to go you go to work and it's like
he is he comes to work the days he's not
shooting he watches you guys shoot him
and McCrory have some notes he was to
the gym he goes to the editing room he
goes to the set to look at the set
they're going to be shooting on next
month he's producing the film and doing
and doing and doing and then you get on
the set and he's made so many movies I
mean how many movies is Tom Cruise made
big movies and he sit there and go this
isn't working for me and him in
Mukwonago and they sit at a table and
they do some dialogue polish he's not
afraid to use the power that he has and
the authority that he has on behalf of
making it right I've worked with movie
stars
who come to work and when the scene
isn't working it's because they're
hungover and they go when their trailer
and they take a nap for an hour and they
come back and maybe they're like ready
for another round who's never rests he's
like a shark he shoots you know what's
that line that Richard Richard Dreyfuss
says they eat they swim and they make
little sharks and that's Cruz he was
just is so dedicated he's so intense and
it's intoxicating I love working with
him I love him making those movies as
always
[Music]